الهزات الارتداديه التي تضرب هاتاي مستمره
منذ الصباح وشعرنا بها يعني تقريبا كل نصف
ساعه الى 40 دقيقه هناك هزه ارتداديه كنت
يعني صعدت الى جسر مشاه للتصوير مشهد
وشعرت به جدا هذه شعرت بها جدا هذه لهذه
الارتداديه نحن لا نزال في وسط المدينه
وهذا المبنى الذي يظهر امامك على الشاشه
له قصه بانه اليوم تم اخراج 10 اشخاص منه
احدهم كان على قيد الحياه
ولا تزال عائلات باكملها محاصره تحت هذا
المبنى من ضمنها عائله مغربيه لم تخرج حتى
هذه اللحظه وهم الان يعني يسابقون الزمن
لانهم بما انه خرج شخص على قيد الحياه
كانوا منذ قليل ايضا طلبوا منا ان نخفض
الاصوات لانهم على ما يبدو استمعوا الى
اصوات ناس ناجين هم يعني الان شاهدناهم
يخرجون اغراض وحاجيات لاسر على ما تشبه
كانت غرفه نوم اطفال اخرجوا منها
اكياس
وامور اخرى هذا المشهد خالد في في هاتاي
يتكرر اليوم اعداد المنقذين والفرق لانقاذ
تتزايد بشكل كبير جدا وهنالك تعزيزات
كبيره لانه حجم الدمار لا يزال هائل جدا
هم هذه البنايه تحديدا الان جل الاهتمام
يتركز عليها لانه لانها لم يعني لم يكن
العمل قد بدا بها وبالتالي هنالك عائلات
ومن المؤكد ان هنالك عائلات لا تزال
محتجزه تحت هذه الانقاض وكما قلت لك من
ضمنها عائله مغربيه المفيد جدا والمهم جدا
والذي يبعث الى الامل انهم استخرجوا اليوم
شخصا من هذه البنايه على قيد الحياه وهذا
مهم خالد هذا يعني يجعلنا نرد نعود الى
سؤال الزمن والوقت والايام وكم يستطيع
الانسان ان يمكث ويقاوم تحت الانقاض هذه
شيء مهم وسعيد جدا وبالتالي هنالك امكانيه
لانهم منذ قليل كما قلت لك سمعوا اصوات
اشخاص تحت الانقاض او اشارات معينه وطلبوا
من الجميع ان يخفض صوته كما تلاحظ العمليه
صعبه وليست سهله الاليات الثقيله تدمر
الاسقف الخرسانيه الكبيره وبالتالي فرق
الانقاذ تعمل هم يعني
لا ادري يمكن تشاهد الصور بدقه وما يحدث
العمليه مضنيه ومتعبه جدا طبعا هذا المبنى
هنالك مئات المباني التي
[تصفيق]
الان يطلبون منا خفض الصوت الان طلبوا منا
خفض الصوت خالد لانه هنالك على ما يبدو
صوت احد الناجين تحت الانقاض انا ساستمر
في الحديث ولكن ساخفض صوتي جدا كما تشاهد
اغلق يعني اوقفوا جميع الاليات العمل وهم
يستمعون الان الى صوت احد الناجين
من تحت الانقاض هذا فين هذا المبنى اكرر
خالد بانهم اليوم اخرجوا شخصا على قيد
الحياه وكان في صحه جيده
واخرجوا تسع اشخاص اخرين كانوا توفوا
ورحلوا وهنالك عائلات باكملها لا تزال تحت
هذا المبنى من ضمنها عائله عربيه مغربيه
طيب اذا سنتابع انا لهذا المشهد ربما انت
لا تستطيع الحديث
بشكل طبيعي واضح الان بسبب استمرار هذه
الجهود والطلب ايضا بخفض الصوت هذا هو احد
المباني المحطمه والمدمره ضمن عشرات او
مئات او الاف المباني التي دمرت جراء هذا
الزلزال الذي ضرب اجزاء من تركيا
وسوريا هي احدى هذه المدن التي كان حجم
الدمار فيها كبيرا
الفرق الانقاذ الموجوده الان تحاول قدر
الامكان ان تصل الى ناجين زميل عمار
الهندي من خلال متابعته قال او اشار الى
ان جهود الانقاذ نجحت في انتشال عشره
اشخاص منهم نجم واحد
وان الفرضيه التي يتم عليها الان ما زالت
هي فرضيه يعني العثور على الناجين الان
وحسب ما ذكره ايضا زميل المتواجد في
المنطقه امام هذا المبنى امام هذه الجهود
اعمار يتحدث عن صوت سمعته هذه الفرقه
وتحاول الان ان تزيل الكتل الخرسانيه